the hogwarts express is one of the most
instantly recognizable props in the
entire harry potter series but given the
late 1800s time frame for hogwarts
legacy does it belong in the video game
is the hogwarts express actually a giant
plot hole i think we could actually see
a brand new take on the iconic
locomotive and in today's video i'll
explain why retroreckons who are here
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell and i've noticed
there's a lot of confusion online about
the hogwarts express specifically when
it was originally created i have a
theory as to why and i think it's
primarily due to three reasons number
one google search results two an error
by jk rowling and three the appearance
of the train in the movies let's start
with the google search at the time of
this recording if you were to go online
and google when was the hogwarts express
built you would see the following as a
highlighted answer notice the section in
bold that says april of 1937. as a
result of this i've noticed a lot of
fans online assuming the hogwarts
express wouldn't be in the game since it
takes place in the late 1800s but we
need to read the full excerpt first
they're citing the hp wiki in this
particular bit is actually referencing a
video where the hogwarts express theme
park actor at the wizarding world of
harry potter said the train was a gwr
model 5900 that was built in 1936. in
reality the gwr 5900 doesn't exist and
the locomotive at the theme park is a
gwr 4900 which was built in 1937. but i
would argue that when folks search about
the hogwarts express on google they're
far more likely to be asking when the
fictional model of the original book
series was designed and not the model at
the wizarding world of harry potter in
orlando florida if you agree you can
actually submit feedback to google on
this answer by clicking the little
feedback icon just here so when did jk
rowling intend for the train to have
been built within the canon of the
series using information compiled from
the original series from pottermore and
even cursed child we're left with the
following the minister of magic in the
year 1827 audelene gamble proposed a
muggle solution to the wizarding world
problem of transporting hundreds of
students to a magic school without
attracting the attention of muggles
prior to this point witches and wizards
had been using a variety of methods to
travel to the school including magical
creatures broomsticks and even portkeys
now unsurprisingly pureblood families
weren't too pleased with gamble's
suggestion to use a muggle technology
however she would ultimately go through
with the plan anyway she commissioned
muggle engineers at a company called
crew works to build the train now crew
works is actually a real world company
but more on that in one second now both
the terrain and its tracks were
completed in 1803 but here's the problem
jk rowling made a bit of a continuity
error here because crew at least in the
real world wasn't built until 1840.
king's cross station also wasn't open
for passengers until october of 1852.
now of course here's where i have to
point out that yes this is all fiction
and there are going to be some little
details like this that are off and don't
quite line up from time to time okay
back to the canon though the ministry of
magic used the biggest concealment charm
britain had ever seen as well as 167
memory charms to move the hogwarts
express the muggle engineers all awoke
the next morning with a feeling they had
misplaced something but they couldn't
remember what something very very large
the ministry would issue a decree that
required all hogwarts students to travel
via the hogwarts express or not attend
at all of course we all know what
happened in harry potter in the chamber
of secrets when he and ron missed the
train
the crane leaves at exactly 11 o'clock
we've missed it
harry
if we can't get through
maybe mom and dad can't get back now
honestly i think rowling could attempt
to clear this up a bit and make it line
up more with the real world history i
would also argue that google should
change this search result to match the
canon answer rather than using an answer
from the theme park actor as for
hogwarts legacy even with the continuity
errors surrounding king's cross and the
crew works company we should definitely
be seeing the hogwarts express by the
late 1800s which is when the game is set
to take place but then we have to decide
what the train should look like and
that's where our third problem comes
into play how it's pictured in the
movies look the train pictured here is
iconic and it's most likely what all of
us are thinking when we imagine the
hogwarts express the train used for the
films is a castle class steam locomotive
number 5972
known as olton hall this particular
model wasn't actually developed until
around the 1930s there's a fairly
detailed reddit post that breaks down
both the locomotive itself as well as
the carriages we see in the movie i'll
link it down in the video description
below the too long didn't read for the
post is essentially if the devs want to
be true to the late 1800s time period
then the hogwarts express and its
carriages should look radically
different than what we see in the films
i'll be honest with you guys for me
personally i'd be totally fine with them
leaving the hogwarts express exactly as
we see it in the movies i know some like
those in the reddit post above are
passionate about maintaining the
historical accuracy and i get it but for
me it's just not something that would
personally break the immersion for me
because that movie design is so iconic i
wouldn't be surprised at all if the devs
at avalanche are just like hey let's
just stick with that design now that
being said if i could choose if i could
decide what's going to happen i would
prefer that they go ahead and change it
preferably to something that's their own
interpretation and also something that
would fit within the late 1800s time
frame if they really wanted to go the
extra mile then we should see some
slight tweaks to the design that would
better match the type of locomotive
likely to have been designed for the
ministry back in 1827. now that reddit
post i mentioned there's also some
comments about what a train from that
time period if it was made that early
what it would have looked like so again
i don't know if they're going to be that
historically accurate i think they
certainly should have the creative
freedom to change things up a bit if
they want after all we are talking about
art here and art is always subject to
interpretation consider that the
hogwarts express in the movies doesn't
match up exactly with the train featured
on the cover of the original british
version of harry potter and the
philosopher's stone also in 2015 artist
jim k had a completely different take
for the hogwarts express which appeared
on the front cover of the new
illustrated edition of sorcerer's stone
now some fans in that very same reddit
post i mentioned earlier seem to think
there's a chance we won't see the
hogwarts express at all given that the
trailer shows someone arriving to the
school by carriage according to the
canon though this would actually be
against the rules put in place by the
ministry once the hogwarts express was
implemented it is the required method of
transportation for students when
traveling to and from the school of
course we also know they don't always
land right there on the hogwarts crowds
it depends on what year they are in
school we all know about the first years
and how they sail across on the black
lake and then there are various other
ways that harry gets to the school
throughout the rest of the books now we
do already know that our character
receives a late acceptance letter to
attend hogwarts which means i guess that
it's possible our student could require
a special mode of transportation to the
school if they're arriving after
everyone else i'm not quite sure that's
what they mean though by late acceptance
letter if the old leaks hold to be true
then that late acceptance letter
actually refers to our character
starting school in year 5 rather than as
a traditional first year we don't really
know why that's the case just yet for my
personal take i think it would really be
a shame if we don't travel to the school
in the hogwarts express at least see it
in a cut scene just considering how
iconic it is for the entire series and
according to the canon in the late 1800s
all students should be required to
travel to hogwarts on the hogwarts
express do you guys want to see the
hogwarts express in the game and if so
are you hoping avalanche will change its
design let me know in the comments below
if you're new here i've got some videos
on the left and right of the screen that
i think you would really love as always
guys thank you all so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon